history has a tendency to repeat itself
fashion trends come back
slang resurfaces and championship teams
return to dominance but what can people
who live during the 1920s and fans of a
team-based shooter made by valve
possibly have in common an unhealthy
obsession with hats for one and how
about the fact they've lived through the
greatest economic failures known to
mankind in both the real and digital
worlds
the crate Depression as it's known now
sent team fortress 2's economy into a
tailspin and just like the market
collapse of the 1930s things were going
slightly off the rails before the
ultimate disaster struck but perhaps
most disturbingly the crate Depression
was an inside job damage Jason the
script says play title card not cue
dramatic sound effect now for anyone not
aware Team Fortress 2 was the first
western game to adopt a microtransaction
system the game's economy is built on
intricate headwear that spawned the now
popular games as a service model to put
into perspective just how lucrative this
economy has been for valve back in 2017
a financial analyst estimated at the
value of virtual goods in TF news
marketplace was somewhere in the region
of 50 million dollars hats in particular
were known for having ridiculous designs
and even more ridiculous names like the
gentle munition of leisure and the hat
of undeniable wealth and respect
I wonder if wearing an octopus hat in
real life can actually give you those
things anyway there are a ton of hats in
tf2 and on top of being able to craft
and collect them players are able to buy
sell and trade them on a marketplace
with the most sought-after quality being
the unusual variety which can be
acquired by unlocking
man coke rates an unusual used to be a
rock solid marker of an elite player
someone who played the game long enough
to open hundreds of crates or obtained
enough materials to trade for the Hat of
their dreams that were they were willing
to shell out 14 thousand dollars for it
no seriously that actually happened
needless to say there is some serious
money to be made trading this unusual
currency the constant wheeling and
dealing of hats on the steam marketplace
lulled players into a false sense of
security but as it turns out this
financial structure wasn't as stable as
everyone thought on July 25th 2019 an
updated tf2 introduced a disastrous
glitch into the game that caused rare
unusual hats to spawn with 100%
certainty from some in-game crates if
this is true that it's a huge exploit
there's no way this gonna work though
right oh my god it actually works I'm
not even 100% certain my mother loves me
can you blame her not when you say it
like that
anyway remember those crates that I
mentioned earlier normally opening one
would grant you about a 1% chance of
unboxing an unusual hat
but this bugged update through that
ratio at the window causing an event
known as the crate depression but to
understand exactly what the event was
and why it was so disastrous for the
game's economy we need to look back to
the 1920s it was a time when dancing
like Fortnight characters wasn't frowned
upon where the average annual salary was
just enough to cover two internet bills
and it was perfectly normal for people
to wear their dead pets
what the [__] during this time tobacco
companies used to stiffen their
cigarette packs with collectible cards
which proved to be an endless source of
entertainment for the masses and really
this can be seen as a precursor to the
micro transaction model that rose in
China with games like ZT online and has
become fairly standard practice today
anyway while things seem to be on the
up-and-up for the states following World
War one all of that change in October
1929 when the stock market crashed
kicking off the Great Depression so what
is a crash why is it so catastrophic and
what the hell does it have to do with
Team Fortress 2 well a stock market
crash happens when there is a sudden
major drop in stock prices in a section
of the market and that's typically
driven by panic economic factors and yes
more panic
things that used to cost an arm and a
leg essentially became worthless and
this is exactly what happened during tf2
scrape depression unusual hats
functioned as stocks with values that
only seemed to increase which convinced
a lot of people that the gravy train was
never going to stop but with the
overproduction of unusual x' at the
crate bug introduced the overall worth
of once rare commodities began to
drastically plummet back in 1929 s crash
people rushed to withdraw funds from US
banks leaving behind a bankrupt mess
fast-forward 90 years later and tf2
players were frantically attempting to
sell their excess stock of unusual hats
while they still could there were so
many hats available for sale that it
kick-started a full scale deflation
while this was happening
while this was happening the usually
dirt-cheap crates and keys were going
for really high prices because they now
guaranteed unusual drops supply crate 82
for example went from selling a couple
units now for three cents each to 4,000
units an hour to six dollars
needless to say tf2 zhis tablished rules
of trade will rapidly going down the
[__] or something like that I'm not a
[__] economist making matters worse
valve was nowhere to be found
causing tf2 players to become
increasingly paranoid would opening the
bug crates get them in trouble was the
game now unplayable who could they turn
to for answers on top of that the game's
long-standing social hierarchy had been
completely destroyed because unusual is
no longer had meaning veteran players
and noobs became visually
indistinguishable everyone had to stand
in the same soup line now soup again and
of course the community responded the
only way it knew how with a torrent of
hilarious memes finally 24 hours after
the bug had been unleashed valve took to
Twitter to address the situation in an
attempt to calm talks of hat mageddon
but some thought that it was already too
late for that a few possible solutions
were kicked around
but as with any complicated issue that
involves multiple factions someone was
bound to get screwed but after a full
week of deliberation valve returned with
the solution they decided to let
everyone keep the very first glitched
hat they unboxed and trade locked the
rest forever additionally those who
didn't want to keep the untradable items
were offered full refunds putting it
into perspective the total number of
hats valve allowed to be tradable
following the crash represents about a
month's worth of unusual zatt their
regular drop rate players that already
deleted their unboxed unusual sphere and
fan
had their hats restored under the same
conditions that applied to the rest of
the bugged stock thankfully the crisis
was largely averted and the Sun rose
again over the debris of TF two's market
economy a few people got to keep some
cool hats for their characters to wear
which was nice but of course as with
real life there were opportunists who
profited from the carnage seriously it
makes me sick what kind of con artists
would take advantage of regular
hard-working people like that
Raptors hats get your Raptors hats 2019
champions just two hundred and fifty
dollars let me see that
you know miles if you're gonna try to
scam people you could at least spell the
players and names correctly well this
was a poor investment my posture is
getting worse Rigo it's not better yeah
dammit
where's an intern hold my shirt oh damn
it Oh
okay
[Music]